most of the time the many movies and TV
shows of the MCU practically invite fan
speculation and while those fans have
gotten a whole lot right over the years
they've been wide Off the Mark just as
often these are the biggest MCU
predictions that fans got completely
wrong
in the original Infinity Gauntlet comic
book storyline Thanos and his quest to
obtain the six Infinity Stones was
spurred by his affection for Lady Death
the actual personification of well you
know so when it came time to adapt this
Arc into the third and fourth Avengers
movies Marvel fans eagerly speculated on
how the character of Lady Death might
factor into the story one popular
prediction was that Kate blanchett's
character of Heller from Thor Ragnarok
would end up playing the role in
Infinity War most of the speculation was
informed by the scarcity of other
antagonistic women in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe though basically if
you wanted an imposing and malicious
feminine figure that Thanos could fall
for it was basically Heller or nobody
this concept only became further
popularized after an interview with Mark
Ruffalo in which the actor indicated
that Blanchette was going to feature in
the two Avengers sequels of course
Blanchard never appeared in either of
these movies let alone as the movie
version of Lady Death in fact this
Hallmark's aborting character from the
comics hasn't appeared in the MCU at all
but the films opting to give Thanos a
new motivation for enacting his campaign
of galaxy-wide genocide and sure taking
this route had its advantages for the
films themselves but it did sadly mean
dashing away the hopes of Marvel fans
who wanted to see Blanche hits Heller
and Thanos sharing some romantic screen
time
for a very long time there was rampant
speculation among Marvel fans over where
the Soul Stone would show up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the first five
of the stones are debuted in four
different titles in the franchise so it
stood to reason that another of the
movies was going to introduce the sick
at some point before infinity War hit
theaters among the many theories fans
concocted for example was a suggestion
that the Soul Stone could have been in
wakanda or that had show up in one of
the Netflix shows one of the most
popular theories of all argued the
Heimdall held the key to this
particularly powerful Stone the idea was
that Heimdall himself was a keeper of
the Soul Stone because it was the same
color as his eyes the theory was
bolstered by a line in the Dark World in
which Heimdall refers to his All-Seeing
power
from here I could see nine Realms and 10
trillion Souls
so yeah it was a bit of a stretch but
since home doll was set to reappear in
Thor Ragnarok before infinity War it's
not like his deeper involvement in the
Infinity Stones Arc was totally out of
the question in the end however all this
speculation was for naught not only did
Heimdall not have the final infinity
stone but Marvel actually chose to keep
the Soul Stone totally out of sight
until Infinity War hit theaters
Doctor Strange was a largely
self-contained entry in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe save for a few name
drops on that mid-credits encounter
between doctor strange and Thor the
movie was more concerned with setting up
the magical world of Steven strange than
shoehorning in an appearance from say
the Hulk however many fans predicted
that one line from Doctor Strange was
supposed to set up a Marvel Superhero to
be the line appears right before
stranger's fateful car crash just as
he's trying to decide which new patient
he should take on how about a 22 year
old female with an electronic implant in
her brain to control schizophrenia
struck by lightning that does sound
interesting that woman these fans argued
was Carol Danvers speculation over this
Theory only went into overdrive when Dr
Strange director Scott Derrickson gave a
pretty ambiguous response to it when
asked by Entertainment Weekly if the
line was referencing Carol Danvers
Derrickson replied remember that
Brittany Murphy movie where she goes
I'll never tell several fans interpreted
this cryptic response as confirmation
that Captain Marvel's origin story had
been hinted that and Doctor Strange of
course this would turn out to be
impossible given that Captain Marvel
takes place in the 1990s decades before
derrickson's movie that alone as well as
the fact that nothing about Captain
Marvel involved getting struck by
lightning makes a whole thing seem
ridiculous but that's the benefit of
hindsight for you
in the first Iron Man movie Jarvis
advises Tony Stark that he should work
on trying to keep the Iron Man's suit
from freezing when entering the upper
parts of Earth's atmosphere just in case
he's planning on going to space anytime
soon while Stark briefly traveled to the
cosmos and the climax of The Avengers
there was much speculation that Iron Man
3 would be the movie that saw the
titular superhero spending a
considerable more amount of time in
outer space this Theory intersected with
fan speculation that Stark would have
some kind of encounter with the
Guardians of the Galaxy in Iron Man 3.
as a way of setting up their own
impending Solo movie it didn't exactly
hurt when sides like screen Crush
reported in January 2013 that the toy
line for Iron Man 3 would include new
Iron Man armor designed for space travel
of course in reality this turns out to
be yet another instance of Superhero
Movie toys featuring a costume made
exclusively for Walmart's shelves Tony
Stark stayed firmly on planet Earth and
Iron Man 3 and it wouldn't be until
Infinity war that the character would
finally meet the Guardians of the Galaxy
before the release of the Avengers there
was constant speculation about which
villain Earth's Mightiest Heroes would
fight in their big screen debut after
all you don't bring together a gaggle of
superheroes for just any occasion there
has to be someone truly special for them
to square off against this fact helped
Inspire persistent Rumblings at the
Scrolls would serve as the other worldly
foes for the likes of Tony cap and Thor
with Scream rans adding more fuel to the
fire by reporting a year before the
movie's release that the Scrolls would
be its primary adversaries the Scrolls
made sense as antagonists for the
Avengers thanks to their ubiquity in the
comics and the fact that the movie had
long been officially confirmed to
feature Cosmic threats who better to
fill that role of course in the end this
Theory turned out to be entirely wrong
in The Avengers the lesser-known chitari
race are the aliens a team goes up
against funnily enough this is a rare
piece of fan speculation that wasn't
entirely off base with the reality of
the movies as the chitari did initially
serve as a counterpass to the Scrolls in
the Ultimate Marvel comic book lion
in the comics a demon known as Mephisto
has a rich history indeed one that's
closely connected to many of the
characters who showed up in one division
given his proximity to the show's
protagonist it's probably not much of a
surprise that many fans spread all kinds
of theories about how Mephisto might
factor into the fantastically weird
Disney plus Series in the end however
Mephisto had no presence of any kind in
one Division and the show's head writer
Jack Schaefer said this was a conscious
Choice she explained her deadline we
didn't think this series needed a big
bad I mean the big bad is grief you know
and that's the story that we were
telling and then we got a Bonus body in
the form of Agatha Harkness who ended up
facilitating wonders therapy I think we
feel pretty good about that on top of
that Schaefer said she didn't even know
about mephisto's existence until she was
done working on the series she explained
there was never any conscious intention
on my part to create any Mephisto red
herrings because I didn't know who
Mephisto was until I started doing press
Avengers Age of Ultron was widely
promoted as being a significantly darker
movie compared to the original Avengers
with all the talk of a somber tone it
was only a matter of time before online
fan theories turned to whether or not
one of the Avengers would bite the dust
before the movie's end before its
release a fan favorite pick for the
doomed Avengers wasn't none other than
the God of Thunder this was a concept
that gained a lot of steam among certain
MCU fans with some people today still
believing Forster Miser ultron's hands
would have fit snugly into the film's
narrative but in the actual age of
Ultron movie Thor was given far less
important things to do his Infamous cave
sequence became a constant source of
ridicule while the sort of Avenger who
was killed ended up being the Newbie
superhero Quicksilver
you didn't see that coming
[Music]
Phil coulson's death in The Avengers was
one of the most moving moments in the
entire movie and that solidified the
character's popularity among MCU fans
with Carlson resurrected for Agents of
Shield torque inevitably turned to how
this agent could re-enter the movie side
of the franchise this speculation was
especially prominent in the lead-up to
Age of Ultron however the movie's writer
and director Joss Whedon felt quite
strongly that Coulson should remain dead
when it came to the mcu's Big Screen
Adventures in an interview around the
time of the movie's release he said as
far as I'm concerned in this movie
colson's Dead it's a different world now
and you have to run with that fans may
have been convinced Age of Ultron was
the perfect time to bring back Coulson
but at that time in Marvel history
whedon's word was pretty much law
it was always known that Infinity War
would bring almost all of the mcu's
Silver Screen superheroes together for
the very first time what was far less
certain was that the franchises
television superheroes would also be
invited to the party specifically lots
of fans found themselves wondering
whether or not the Netflix Defenders
superheroes could show up and if so how
would they factor into the movie's story
earlier comments from Marvel Studios
brass had indicated that such characters
could show up in any of the movies
including the long-awaited crossovers in
Infinity war and end game in the end
these Heroes never made it into either
movie but that doesn't mean the
filmmakers behind the film weren't
speculating about their involvement just
as much as the fans speaking to inverse
on the subject writer Stephen mcfeely
said we talk about that all the time in
a movie this big we certainly have the
conversation should we put Luke Cage in
this here we are in New York that kind
of stuff as you could probably tell it
would be just a glorified Cameo at this
point he and co-writer Christopher
Marcus also brought up the difficult if
expecting moviegoers to simultaneously
keep tabs on theatrical movies and the
Netflix shows thus the Defenders despite
so much fan speculation remain small
screen Heroes for now
at the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 2 nebula departs a new comrades to
pursue her abusive adoptive father
Thanos the somberness of her farewell
and the emphasis on her departure seemed
to many Marvel fans like a potential
sets up to the character's death in
Infinity war or end game the concept of
nebula biting the dust and these
Avengers movies further fueled by her
personal connection to the Mad Titan
proved so popular that she was chosen by
Business Insider as one of the
characters most likely to die in
Infinity War however all the speculation
proved to be totally Off the Mark the
perversion of nebula did die in end game
the original nebula survived both films
and even became one of the lead
characters in the latter right now she
is expected to appear in Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 in 2023 and even beyond
that movie The sky's the limit for
nebula check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]